Let's examine again
an object that's
undergoing circular motion.
And we'll choose our polar
coordinates r hat, theta hat.
We'll make it
cylindrical with a k hat.
Now that we've completed
our kinematic description
of the motion, now let's see
how we apply Newton's second law
to circular motion.
Well, when we write
Newton's second law as F
equals ma, that-- remember,
we can divide these two sides.
This side, the how, is
a geometric description
of the motion.
And this side is
the why, and this
is the dynamics of the motion.
And the dynamics come from
analyzing the forces that
are acting on this object.
So when we're applying
this mathematically
to circular motion, F equals
ma-- this is a vector equation.
And so what we need to do is
think about each component
separately.
Sometimes I can just
distinguish the components
that I'm talking
about over here.
And so we have that the radial
component of the forces--
and that comes from an
analysis of the dynamics,
the physics of the problem--
and this side is mass times
the radial component of
the acceleration, ar.
Now these are very
different things.
And it's by the
second law that we're
equating in quantity
these two components.
Now if we wrote that equation--
this side out in a little bit
more detail-- we'll
save ourselves
a little space when we handle
the tangential direction--
the forces come from analysis
of free body force diagrams.
And over here, we know the
acceleration is always inward.
And I'll choose to write
this as r omega squared.
And so this will be
our starting point
for analyzing the radial
motion for an object that's
undergoing circular motion.
Now remember, there could
be a tangential motion, too.
And in the tangential
direction, the tangential forces
are equal to ma tangential.
And as we saw, this is
again the second law,
equating two different things.
We have that we can write
the tangential force as r
d squared theta dt squared.
And sometimes we've been
writing that as r alpha z.
But this equation
here is what we're
going to apply for
the tangential forces.
If the tangential forces
are 0, then there's
no angular-- there's no
tangential acceleration.
We know that for
circular motion,
the radial force
can never be zero,
because this term
is always non-zero
and points radially inward.
And now we'll look at
a variety of examples
applying Newton's second
law to circular motion.